what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are picking up with a
terrific s-- which are essentially DC's
fantastic Fork but better that's one of
the funny things a lot of people tend to
forget when it comes to the Fantastic
Four is people sort of have like this
idea to look at the team and say what's
the Fantastic Four the greatest thing
ever
not really they were great in like the
60s and then when you got into the mid
70s going up and - all the way to the
1990s they kind of sucked and then
Jonathan Hickman took over and Jonathan
Hickman had a great run but no the
Fantastic Four their cut their line of
comics were garbage for like 25 years
they were not very interesting at all
nonetheless this is actually super cool
now here's the thing about the
terrific's they come out of the whole
dark multiverse thing right now I
remember we talked about that during the
events of Dark Knights metal where we
basically talked about how comic book
publishers will release one of three
kinds of major stories either it's a
reboot story like flashpoint wise which
is designed to basically reset
everything back to zero it's a story
like DC Universe rebirth number one
which is designed a kind of undo
flashpoint essentially or it's a story
like Dark Knight's metal which is
designed to introduce new things and so
what this does is this initially picks
up with Java always called him Java I
don't know I don't know what else you
would call but were met with the arrival
of mr. terrific now the idea of mr.
terrific goes all the way back to like
1942 with sensation comics number one
and that was actually a guy named Harry
Sloan and he was created by a guy named
Charles Rio Charles risin Steam
sensation comics were a line of comments
which much like action whiz comics
Detective Comics so on and so forth they
were basically anthology series meaning
that there were multiple stories
contained in each comic book the
original Terry Sloan lasted for quite
some time really until the Golden Age of
comics ended and when we've had videos
where we've talked about how World War
two kind of marked the end of the Golden
Age of comics and most superheroes
dropped off their stories were cancelled
they were basically remove from the
landscape the original Terry Sloane was
one of them now in 1997 John Ostrander
in the third volume of Spectre I'm
pretty sure I introduced Michael Holt he
introduced the new mr. terrific and
Michael Holt was a guy who's really just
a genius I mean that's this the idea
behind it but nonetheless when it comes
to someone like when it comes to a group
like the terrific think of mystery or
mister terrific himself as basically
Reed Richards that's essentially the
role that it comes down to - the ability
to stretch but it's cool because he
basically shows up here to visit a guy
named Simon stack and the reason
he's visiting Simon Stagg is because
Stagg basically acquired all the assets
of of hold industries legally in the
sense that during the events of dark
nights metal Holt Industries kind of
fell into disarray or at least has seems
to have been the case a lot of that
happened off panel but Simon Stagg
bought it you know through legal means
so there's really not a whole lot that
Michael Holt can do about it now for
Simon Stagg sapphire and Java they are
old school like I mean they they're
they're øg øg I mean they go back a long
time and they really go back to the
origin story and the initial appearance
of Metamorpho which is very very great
for us because Metamorpho shows up here
now rex was a guy who was really kind of
like an explorer so to speak but more so
than that he was looking to gain the
attention of sapphire stack the daughter
of simon and so what ended up happening
is Simon just more or less kind of duped
him into traveling to Egypt Rabi
something called the orb of rock and
then sent JA but it basically take him
out and then grab the orb for himself
this led to Metamorpho season the orb
gaining his powers the ability to kind
of adapt to everything and the result is
that he's you know the current way that
he is right now with Metamorpho he's
well originally he was able to transmit
himself based on existing earthly
elements or elements found within the
body that shifted and now he could
basically turn himself to any number of
elemental states and actually combine
elements to create a wide array of
different compounds but he's one of
these guys where he can depending on the
circumstance make himself indestructible
and when I say depending on the
circumstance I mean depending on the foe
he's facing off against I mean if it's
like somebody who can control the
fundamental forces of the universe
there's not much he can do the funny
thing about him though is that he was
always one of these guys who depending
on the story he could be serious but
more often than not he was just kind of
uh well I would say a guru sort but
maybe not really a goof so much like a
holdover from 1960s coming books
storytelling what we know finding out is
that with Michael Holt showing up here
and realizing that what Simon Stagg had
done was basically open a portal to the
dark multiverse he responds by
implementing a plastic man now this
whole scenario with Plastic Man it's
kind of intriguing here because when you
have Michael Holt I'm sorry not Michael
Holt when you have Metamorpho there's a
reason why he is the way he is and turns
out why he's lashing out we'll find out
here in a second but Plastic Man making
his return is one of those interesting
things for a lot of people who were
longtime fans of DC Comics were just to
say they've been reading since the early
1990s when you consider these
20-some odd years have come a big
reading classic man was always one of
these guys where he had he brought in
kind of like a comedic tone his presence
was very much noticed when
what when who was missing during the
events of new 52 and him being on the
terrific is actually a great fit forced
character is absolutely genius by DC to
throw him on this and hopefully at last
for the long term but the idea behind
this is that he just kind of shows up
and essentially wakes up and this is
really the first time he's really what
really awoken besides his return in Dark
Knight's metal which really kind of
raises the question does he remember
that and the implication seems to be
that he doesn't he doesn't really
remember anything that happened during
the events of Dark Knights metal which
is somewhat intriguing here but then we
start to get this a bit of an
explanation when is it happening as
Plastic Man uses his body to basically
shield
Metamorpho and and and mr. terrific and
the reason for this is because what
metamorphose body had been doing was
absorbing in metal and by doing that
driving him insane now it's kind of a
cool thing because what it means is that
from this point going forward
Metamorpho could invoke in metal which
could allow him to be a pretty handy
weapon against any be that ever arises
from the dark multiverse since we know
that's basically their version of
kryptonite and so because of this we end
up getting this really cool a bit of an
explanation kind of a rehashed by mister
terrific of course explaining the events
of Dark Knight's metal which those of
you guys who haven't who who aren't
familiar with that make sure you check
out the videos on it and go read the
book because Dark Knight's metal is
super cool it's basically evil Batman
the easiest way to explain it but it's
such a complex story you can't really
sum it up in like a minute and a half so
I would say go read the story or go
watch the videos or whichever one
strikes your fancy hopefully that'll
that'll make sense here but the idea was
that Plastic Man had essentially been in
this sort of egg state and kind of like
a shutdown state the entire time and
this is when we sort of get an
explanation that Michael Holt's
essentially reveals that Batman had
learned about the Dark multiverse a long
long time ago and the idea was to take
plastic man and send him in as a probe
because his body is so malleable and
because he's so resistant to damage and
the and because the fact that he'd gone
to the dark multiverse when he came back
he was in his egg form and so no one
really knows what happened that led him
to being confined to that state we just
know that it was a presumably the nature
of the dark multiverse of the fact that
it was so extreme that it shut him down
even Plastic Man himself doesn't fully
recall now this is cool because it gives
room for DC to basically expand on the
adventures of Plastic Man in the dark
multiverse we don't know exactly how
long he was there and we know that time
passes in the dark multiverse
differently than it does in the main DC
Universe and the reason why this matters
is because it gives DC what amounts to a
blank check for telling stories about
positive men but it's essentially this
idea that men
it was kind of an in psychic state more
or less because of how a metal had
impacted him but of course with Plastic
Man protecting them the idea is we have
to essentially break out of here now
Michael Holt mr. terrific is protected
because of his teeth spheres plastic
man's fine because of as his
malleability and the result is that you
know mister terrific basically basically
tells Metamorpho alter your body's
chemistry in this fashion so you'll be
resistant to the effects of the Dark
multiverse and so is essentially that
each one of them has the ability to stay
resistant into themselves now the funny
thing about this is that when they had
gone through the portal what they had
done was essentially land on some
monstrous celestial that's out there now
remember when it comes to the Dark
multiverse there's so much we don't know
even though even you know about Dark
Knights metal you know hit on the tip of
the iceberg there's a zillion other
things that we could focus on here this
giant celestial looks very akin to
Galactus but we have no real clue what
this being is where it came from if it's
even dead or alive whatever the case may
be but then being here sees them of
course being attacked by various spiders
and so on and so forth and that's when
they're met by this girl essentially
this girl just kind of shows up out of
nowhere and it's just kind of like hey
don't attack my friends they're the only
company I have that's not a very cool
thing to do but it's a situation where
she's basically been stuck in a in
tangible form now we end up finding out
this girl's name is lenio waz o which is
kind of a cool name but she hails from
some plan of the stories with a letter B
and I'm not even gonna try to pronounce
this but she seems to basically be a
character from a different universe from
a different reality here now the reason
why we say this is because of the fact
that when it comes to someone like
Michael Holt when it comes to someone
like like mr. terrific he is as
well-versed in the various facets of the
universe and multiverse as anybody
else's because he has to be because of
the nature of his character when you're
dealing with things like Dark Knight's
metal when you're dealing with like the
potential collapse of the multiverse
you're dealing with the aftermath of
that and the idea that the multiverse is
essentially dying by just leaking itself
out into whatever's beyond the source
wall you have to be aware of how the
multiverse functions the fact that he's
not familiar with her is a direct
indication of the fact that she's not
from she's not native to this universe
and so it seems to me that she's just
kind of out from some other universe
somewhere now the whole story that she
offers here the way this situation
unfolds it is actually pretty
interesting is essentially this idea
that she was on a vacation with her
family when a rift a portal to the dark
multiverse open now this is given to us
as an explanation by way of simply
saying the dark multiverses invasion of
the May
BC in a main DC Multiverse itself was
designed to collapse the multiverse much
like you know Darkseid's actions and
Final Crisis and so it is essentially
designed to say the actions of barbados
influenced more than just the main DC
universe that it was out throughout the
entire multiverse that a portal it
opened to the dark multiverse and she
was a she was at least the idea was to
get her to an escape pod and to jettison
her away
so that she'd be at me on much like
Superman so she'd be able to survive the
experience the opposite happen and she
was shot into the portal while the rest
of their while the rest of her family
got away now this whole story also comes
off the heels of the introduction or a
statement that's made that basically
says like this this multiversal beacon
that Michael holding company had hit on
which is what led them to enter the dark
multiverse in the first place then it
was sent out by a guy by the name of Tom
strong now a little bit of kind of a
publishing history here so a lot of
people have heard or at least I'd like
to think a lot of people have heard of
image comics or heard the name reference
Image Comics was founded by a handful of
people who were basically disillusioned
with Marvel Jim Lee and and Alan fine
and a whole bunch of guys so they left
to go for him Image Comics one of these
guys Jim Lee actually branched off and
formed his own creator own line called
wild storm now wild storm was designed
to be this really really cool thing and
if that was huge back in the day like
back in the mid 1990s there was a guy
named Brandon Choi who helped to found
wild storm alongside Jim Jim Lee and ran
a line of stories called Gen 13 people
love Jim 13 it was it was kind of like a
play on Generation X Jim Lee's wild
storm in 1990s was massively popular now
of course as we know the comic book
busts of the mid nineteen nineties fans
almost destroying the industry was hard
for a lot of small-time creators and so
in 1999 wild storm was bought and turned
into a subsidiary of DC but it remained
editorially separate and what that meant
was that Jim lien company had total
control over their characters DC had no
influence on Wildstorm and so for those
of you guys who read flashpoint that's
the reason why wild storm is one of the
things that's rolled into quote-unquote
the new multiverse because it was just a
property that was out there in a wild
storm tom strong was he was more of like
an explorer you know him and his and his
family was kind of like explorers they
would go out and they would see things
ah but he's a kid that we really haven't
seen for a long time with the terrific
so I'm sorry with that with nudity too
with the events of Flashpoint where wild
storm was rolled in to the larger DC
landscape not much was really done with
it and so things like like the terrific
things like you
basically this New Age of Heroes
terrific the immortal men the silencer
sideways damage it's a great way to take
these ideas these these old Wildstorm
characters that we haven't seen for
kasoori or first some time and like
throw them in here in order to give them
a reader base and to help expand on them
and then probably throw them into the
larger DC landscape later on this is
certainly what DC should have done if it
started up the start of new 52 but the
fact remains here you know with this
this young girl because of the fact that
she can't really return to a tangible
state she's really who they just
referred to as phantom girl which is
kind of a cool idea but at the same time
the idea of Michael Holt is to figure
out what you know basically stashes
antenna up we know more or less which is
where this SOS beacon is being sent from
and then examine it figure out you know
who this guy Tom's strong is on and then
try to find a way to locate him so again
not the most important thing ever it's
just a small little subplot that'll be
explored later on but the big takeaway
from all this is that because of their
interactions in the dark multiverse when
they enter back into the main DC
Universe in and start to go their
separate ways like a rubber band being
stretched and then being released they
snap back to each other basically that
if they travel too far apart they'll be
destroyed now in reality this is DC
playing it pretty fast and loose and
just saying hey guys
so here's just a reason for why they
have to be a team and it works it's
actually pretty awesome like don't take
it too seriously you just run with it
and it's so smart but still uh and this
this this kind of funny situation here
they're trying to make their way back
like they're literally trying to figure
out what in the world is going on and
how they can essentially break apart and
not be stuck together how they can just
like avoid each other and it's funny
because it's like so what would it be
like if the Fantastic Four just kind of
hated each other could take each other
in like small doses and then now they
have to take each other in like huge
doses now of course this leads into some
giant robot machine thing attacking the
entire place and that's one of the funny
things to notice about this the story
doesn't really take itself too seriously
but each of them has something cool to
offer one of the things we end up
learning about phantom girl is that when
she returns to the main DC Universe she
regains her ability to become tangible a
byproduct of this is that anything she
touches explodes and so it's basically
like you know this this ex-girlfriend I
used to have everything that she gets
close to essentially dies and so because
of this it's one of these things Wars is
like okay she's got her own little
caveat and kinda has to stay in an in
tangible form at the same time when you
have this whole situation of classic
kind of being a goof but also being
extremely durable and capable in terms
of his malleability as well as
Metamorpho you know basically basically
kind of being the guy who hits stuff it
becomes cool it becomes the Fantastic
Four now of course this machine is dealt
with quick fast and in a hurry
it's not designed to be a great big huge
thing now this of course leads to
Michael Holt basically questioning Simon
Stagg and saying are you the one behind
this and it's like well no of course not
so basically it's essentially saying
they have an enemy out there somewhere
who this enemy is and where they're
coming from we don't entirely know but
still like it's interesting because
they're basically guys you don't really
tolerate each other too much but they
kind of have to come together as a team
and the first real team effort they have
is like they have to go get something to
eat look we're exhausted man like let's
get some food or something let's go
chill but the whole point really the
whole focus of Michael Holt at this
moment is to figure out who taught
Armstrong is to figure out who this guy
is now this is awesome because what it
could mean is a Tom strong can basically
come back and say hey here's like this
whole thing in the dark multiverse
here's all these things that you can
explore and basically be not necessarily
a guide but a person who can start
pointing them in directions and say go
over there and you go explore those
things it really gives the ability for
the terrific to break beyond expanding
the universe and go expand the dark
multiverse and by proxy of them give us
the ability to see all the things that
are out there a planet of evil like a
universe of evil Superman what if the
Green Lantern's were bad guys and the
red lanterns were good guys there's all
these cool scenarios that we can explore
out there and it would actually be
pretty awesome but without being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here - comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later
[Music]
[Music]